>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary Quattlebaum: So, I'm so glad
to be here today on this rainy day
to celebrate a spectacular voice
in teen literature, Sabaa Tahir.
[ Applause ]
This is actually great because after
every sentence everybody applauds.
[Laughs] Sabaa is also a
former Washington Post editor.
And in her job at the post
she says she learned much
about the high stakes
politics around the world
that surfaces in her fantasy novels.
Sabaa grew up in the Mojave Desert.
And her parents are both
immigrants from Pakistan.
This has also led her to be
an advocate for diverse voices
in young people's literature.
And we thank her for her advocacy.
Sabaa's first novel, "An Ember
in the Ashes" was an
immediate bestselling success.
The novel's setting
inspired by ancient Rome,
an intricate plot grabbed
readers around the world.
We closed that book wondering what
would happen to the slave girl,
Laia, and the young soldier, Elias?
The next book in the Ember
series came out last year.
Critics praised "A Torch Against the
Night" as compelling and complex.
Sabaa's many readers can hardly wait
for the third book "A
Reaper at the Gates."
It comes out this spring.
We are lucky to have Sabaa Tahir
as both an author and
an advocate today.
She'll be signing her
books from noon to 1 p.m.
And please join me
in welcoming Sabaa.
[ Applause ]
>> Sabaa Tahir: Wow, I was nervous.
But I'm not nervous any more.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you for being here today.
I'm really happy to .
. . hold on.
Clicker. I'm really happy to be
in D.C. and talk about myself
for the next 20 minutes or so.
No, I'll talk about my books, too.
And also my childhood.
I'm not that selfish.
So, I'm going to.
. . Sorry.
Okay, yes.
So, I'm going to talk
about something very near
and dear to my heart today.
It's been one of my constant
companions since I was a young Ba,
who first entered school long ago.
I'm going to talk about
my old friend, failure.
So, I started failing young.
I still remember my very
first instance of failure.
This is me.
And speaking of failure.
And this is a little off topic.
But let's talk about the haircut.
I feel like every South Asian mom
in the world has given their
daughter this haircut at some point.
And I think they all
get together in a room.
And they're drinking Chia.
And they're like what
can we do to make sure
that our daughters
have no self-esteem.
So, they never talk to a boy.
Ever. I know.
Let's give them like 16th
century pageboy haircut.
When they're five or six.
That'll do it.
It worked by the way.
Thanks, Mom.
Anyway, I was in first grade and
I got a D on a spelling test.
My parents lost it.
Pandemonium.
Like a child of my father's
getting a D. It did not matter
that I was six.
This was like the shame
of the household.
I was busted.
And I got this big
speech from my parents.
About how I had to
work twice as hard.
I mean, everything, I
got put on lockdown.
Right? No Barbies.
No playdates.
No super soakers with my
bro in the hot desert sun.
It was like spelling
morning, noon, and night.
No roller skates.
They were like, no, you
can't do any of that.
So, it was spelling morning, noon,
and night until I was
a master at it.
I remember sulking in the room that
I shared with my Mom and my Dad.
And wondering what is the big deal?
Even as a six-year-old, I
knew I was a six years old.
And I was like this is not
the end of the world, guys.
My parents didn't see it that way.
That didn't want the taint
of failure in the house.
So, very young I learned, not just
to hate failure, but to fear it.
Fearing it sadly did not
stop it from happening.
Sometimes, I think, the more
afraid that you are of something,
the more likely it is to
come knocking at your door.
It's sort of like of when I was
allergic to my brother's cat,
it would always come and sit on me.
Like it knew.
It hated everyone else but
it knew I was allergic to it.
So, it would come and sit on my lap.
I failed at many more
spelling tests.
And math. God, math.
This is me and math.
And that's not an exaggeration.
Just out of curiosity.
How many of you guys
like enjoy math?
How many of you are math people?
I don't understand you.
I'm sorry.
I just, never going to get it.
Anyway. As I got older,
I started fearing failure
as much as my parents did.
Because the cost was higher.
If I failed a test in high
school it affected my grades.
And that affected my chance
of getting into college.
And I lived in this
really small town
and I wanted nothing
more than to leave.
So, I got to the point where
one failure, at one thing,
would sort of send me
into a spiral of doubt.
If I failed at a test.
If I, you know, let a friend down.
If I screwed something up.
If I was late to something.
I would kind of get
worked into a frenzy.
And at this point, I wasn't
learning from my failures.
I just wanted to avoid them.
And I never examined my failures.
I didn't forgive myself for them.
I just got really,
really, angry at myself.
And I hated myself.
And my self-esteem just tanked.
Some of these by the way, like don't
relate to what to what I'm saying.
I just thought they were funny.
So, this is one of them.
Oh, it's Calvin and
Hobbs, I'll put that up.
That'll be great.
So, I personified failure
in my head.
It became a capital F.
And I could hear her.
She was like a person.
I could her murmuring in my ear.
And she was telling
me how much I sucked.
And how bad I was at everything.
I'm going to explain
this in just a second.
So, this whole thing
continued until college.
And through my very, very
first summer internship,
which was at the Washington Post.
I was 21 years old.
And I went into it
like really excited.
And I failed so much that summer.
It was spectacular.
I was a copy editor.
So, I was supposed to write
headlines on the international desk.
And I screwed them up all the time.
I insulted reporters, accidentally.
I flouted like Washington
Post grammar style.
I remember one time there was a
report who was like a real big shot.
And he was calling from Iraq.
And he was filing from the back
of a truck and I hung up on him.
On accident.
And he couldn't get back on
the sat phone to call us.
And I was like, Blah.
And I think my finest moment was
actually when I spelled Colombia,
the country, as Columbia
the University.
And it was in headline
on the front page.
But thank God there was
a proofer who saved me
from that particular humiliation.
And I didn't have like
one of those really,
like fluffy, like sweet nice bosses.
Who was like let me guide you
through your first internship.
No, no, no.
No. He was like a hard ass.
And he was going to make sure
that I, but also everyone
in the immediate vicinity,
knew when I had failed.
He had a very penetrating voice.
So, failure like usual
started talking to me again.
And telling me how terrible I was.
And, again, my self-esteem
took this real hit.
I would call my Mom
every day that summer.
And I would wail to her
about how I didn't belong
at the Washington Post.
And she would listen to me
and she would like pet me,
you know, over the phone.
And be like, it's going to be okay.
It's going to be okay.
Pull it together.
Right? So, I started realizing,
really quickly, that if I wanted
to continue to work at the finest
news organization in the world,
I did not have time to listen
to that voice inside of my head.
Telling me that I was the worst.
I did not have time to give it any
attention because I didn't want
to be thrown out onto the street
outside the Washington Post.
I couldn't sit there and wallow
in how much I sucked, frankly.
So, I was going to have
to learn from my failure.
But not just learn from it.
I was going to have to get
very comfortable with failure.
Because I would be failing
again, and again, and again.
And I could not let
that voice cripple me
and leave me in a spiral of doubt.
I couldn't let that voice take over.
So, I started the very, very, very
uncomfortable process of starting
to think about why I had failed.
It was the only way to survive.
So, when I messed up a
headline, I started writing
down what was wrong with it.
And when I took on too much and
got yelled for not turning it
in on time, I started writing
down, don't take on too much.
And slowly, failure became
not an enemy but a teacher.
And it was one of the
longest summers of my life.
When I got to the end,
I was pretty sure
that my boss would either
completely ignore me
and be like, please, leave.
Or that he would just walk
over and say, you know,
it was interesting having
you here and good luck
in your career as something else.
But instead, something
very strange happened.
I sat in the newsroom.
I was kind of in the
center of the newsroom.
And there were all these
reporters and editors around.
And some of them were
these huge names.
And they had won Pulitzer Prizes
and they had movies
based off their books.
A few of them started coming over.
And they were like, hey, you
know, you did a really good job.
And I was like .
. . were you .
. . are you talking
about the same person?
Do I have a twin in the room
who knows what she's doing?
But they were like, no, no, no.
We heard. We saw.
But you learned.
And you got better.
And then low, my boss comes over.
And tells me that he
would love for me to apply
for another internship
the next year.
Because he wanted me to come back.
So, that he could work with me again
and hopefully, hire me one day.
And that was the first time, in my
life, that I had failed so miserably
and I did not hate myself for it.
Which was good.
Because a few years later I
would fail spectacularly, again,
and I would need to
remember that lesson.
So, fast forward to 2007.
Through the very, very
cunning use of the dark arts,
I procured a job at
the Washington Post.
No, I'm kidding.
I didn't use dark arts, I just
bribed them with chocolate.
Lots of it.
But I had been working this
night job as a copy editor.
And I'd been reading
all sorts of stories
about child soldiers and genocide.
And terrible things
happening in the world.
And I read this one.
And this is a story by Emily Wax,
who is still a reporter at the Post.
And it is about women in Kashmir and
how their families, their brothers,
fathers, sons were taken
by the local military
and thrown into prison.
And sometimes they were
given no reason why.
They couldn't get their
family members out.
And they were kind of stuck living
in this half world while
that was happening.
And I remember this
story haunted me.
Because I have brothers.
And I was like, what if
that happened to them.
This is not out of the
realm of possibility.
What if I lived in that place.
And I couldn't get this
story out of my head.
So, I kind of put together all these
news pieces that I had been reading.
And I started getting an
idea for a fiction book.
And all I had of this was
this girl and her brother.
And a Jin who is bent on revenge.
And I got the Jin idea from
the stories my mom told me
as a little girl, scare
the daylights out of me.
And I started working on it.
Not because I think anything
is going to come of it.
But because it's like
a bee in bonnet.
I just can't get it out of my head.
So, this is one of those
ones that's not related.
But I just put it up there.
So, for months I would work on this
story at night, during the day.
I would work on it when I
was supposed to be sleeping.
was supposed to be cleaning.
When I was supposed to be
hanging out with family.
It was my obsession.
And as I poured out
words, I wrote one draft.
And it was like really bad.
And then after two, I
decided to quit my job.
I'd had a child.
I was going to stay home with
him and I was going to write
in whatever time that I could get.
So, I did that.
And by 2010, I had been working
on the book for about 3 1/2 years.
And I had a draft that I
was really excited about.
So, at the time, I had
like three readers.
Two of them, I sent it to them.
And they read and they
gave me some notes.
And they generally liked it.
And I was this is great.
I can go and see if
I can find an agent.
This is going to be wonderful.
Then I gave it to my third reader.
And I was really nervous
about his comments.
And he came back and his
comments were extensive.
And something about it annoyed me.
Because I did not have a thick skin.
And I felt like he didn't get it.
I was like, you don't get the book.
You don't understand.
And we argued about this.
Because he has strong feelings, too.
And he said that I was
dismissing his advice.
And I was like, no, you're an idiot.
And at the end of this
argument he said,
your book is an unmitigated
disaster.
Yes, right?
That was not a good feeling.
This is not me.
But it is very close to what
I looked like after that.
So, I did not know how to respond.
Because he really believed it.
And the thing is, I
really believed him.
I really respected his opinion.
He was an extensive reader.
He was a great writer.
And I was totally crushed.
So, I had failed.
I had like really failed.
I had spent three years
on something.
I had poured my soul into it.
And it had just failed so badly.
And I didn't know what to do.
I thought, you know, I
need to shelve this book.
I need to put it away.
I can't work on it anymore.
So, I went through what
my dear friend, Liz,
calls "a dark knight
of the creative soul."
I was pretty certain I was done.
I didn't want to write again.
I didn't want to write
anything else.
This was the story.
And if I couldn't do
it, I wasn't interested.
I got really down, guys.
I'll be real.
I was watching, like, reruns of
the "Shawshank Redemption" on TNT.
And I was eating Ben and Jerry's
straight out of the carton.
It was bad.
But I started looking at the notes.
Eventually, my stubbornness
rose to the surface.
And I started looking at the
notes that this guy had given me.
And I started trying
to figure out, why,
why is it an unmitigated disaster?
And there was a pattern.
There was sort of a method
to what seemed like chaos
within what he was saying.
I was like, oh, I think
he had a point.
No, I'll have to sorry or worse.
So, it turns out, though, that
in those three years of writing
and rewriting, and rewriting.
I had actually learned something.
And I'd realized that I had
failed in character arcs.
And I had failed in world building.
And there were a lot of mistakes.
But my old friend, failure, she
was murmuring in my ear again.
But this time, she was
telling me what to fix.
She was telling me how to fix it.
She was saying, you have done this
before and you can do this again.
So, that was not the
last time I failed.
That draft was better.
But it wasn't the final.
The final took 2 1/2 more
years before it was even ready
for me to send it to an agent.
And another year after
that it was pretty ready.
So, from the day I thought
of the idea to the day it was
on the shelf was seven
years and ten months.
And it felt like 84 years.
It felt like forever.
And it just felt like an eternity.
So, life is full of failure.
If you're a writer, a student, a
doctor, a truck driver, a parent,
a child, it doesn't
matter what you do.
You are going to fail.
It's this uncomfortable
feeling at its best.
And it is miserable at its worst.
But I started to realize that
failure is not just something
that I have to get past or
something I have to survive.
It is something that I
have to see as essential.
If sometimes an unpleasant
part of my life.
It's sort of like exercising.
Or like having Thanksgiving dinner
with relatives, who
you are like, no.
Let's not talk about politics.
So, I think .
. . no. Okay.
Well, it's supposed to go back
to the beginning but it didn't.
No worries.
I'm going to talk about
my most recent experience
with failure to sort
of wrap this up.
And it was very recent.
It was this year.
I failed at writing my third book.
I failed at it for months.
And months, and months.
And months.
I was too distracted by the
political situation going on.
I couldn't get into the story.
I wrote a full draft.
It was a nightmare.
Like, if any of you guys
saw it, you'd be like.
. . It was so bad.
And then I rewrote
it, and rewrote it.
And actually, two nights ago, at
11:59 p.m. on the day it was due,
I turned in my third book.
[ Applause ]
But every moment until the moment
that my husband, who was standing
across from me, was like oh, my God.
It's 11:59, turn it in.
Like send.
Send it now.
Every moment felt like a failure.
Failure is your teacher.
It is your tool.
It is your fuel.
And it is your friend.
It does not teach you
what you've done wrong.
It teaches you what
you've done right.
Failure will remind
you of your weaknesses?
Absolutely.
But it will also remind
of your strengths.
And I think most importantly it
reminds you about who you are.
About what your made of.
And about how far you have come.
So, if you have questions,
particularly about failure,
please come and ask them.
That's it.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
No questions?
No one? Oh, I see questions.
Okay. Please come to the mic.
>> Hi. First of all, I would
just like to thank you so much
for being here and I
love your book so much.
And I love that you're
a Pakistani writer.
And that you .
. . it just means so much
to me because I've wanted
to be a writer for so long.
And just, I haven't seen
myself in that space.
I'm part of so many writing
spaces and bring diversity
to writing spaces is a cause
near and dear to my heart.
I just wanted to thank so much.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Oh,
thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
[Applause]
>> My question is could
you talk a little bit
about someone's challenges you
faced when, in world building.
Because when it comes
to my writing I like,
fantasy is one of my
favorite things.
But one of the challenges
I come across is trying
to know how much information
needs to be relayed to the reader.
Like, how much I need to know
how much needs to be related
to the reader when it
comes to world building?
So, how do you balance
that and just what are some
of the challenges you faced?
>> Sabaa Tahir: So, I don't
think there is like a hard .
. . It's a great question.
I don't think there is
a hard and fast rule.
But I sort of followed this
thing called The Iceberg Rule,
which is like, I don't
actually know any numbers.
So, if I get this wrong, apologies.
But it's like 70% of the iceberg
in under the water or
something like that.
So, it's sort of like
that with world building.
Where 70% of my world
building is just in my head.
And then 30% is what
I show on the page.
And then in terms of how to world
build, I would say, I generally tend
to start with my characters
and build out from there.
The other thing is,
I write in iteration.
So, I don't try to have my
world perfect the first time.
I build the world as I edit.
And I add in different ideas and,
you know, whether it's architecture
or art, or you know, the
military and how it's designed.
Whatever that it, it goes
through in iterations.
And then once you've,
if you're doing fantasy,
you might be doing a series.
Once you've sort of
start your series,
you will see that it gets
easier as you go along
because you've built
the world already.
The rest of the writing
still sucks, by the way.
By the world building
is a little bit easier.
So, I would say, try not to
put quite as much up front.
And let it kind of emerge
as you write the book.
You can always add world
building if someone is
like I don't understand this.
But it's a little harder
to kind of take it
out once you've already put it in.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
Why don't we go to this side?
>> Hi. So, I was wondering if you
had any insights about, I think,
usually failure is thought of
as being something external.
You know, that you're disappointing
other people's expectations.
How have you found a
way to get past failure
in your mind before
it even happened?
For me, I was a writer,
what's always been hardest,
either as somebody who's studied a
lot of literature, I think, oh God,
this isn't Jane Austen's.
What's the point of even doing it?
Or, you know, if you were a real
writer then you would be writing
every spare minute you possibly had.
And you're not doing that.
So, clearly you're not
cut out for this world.
Just find a grownup job.
Have you had anything like that?
>> Sabaa Tahir: I have.
Yes. I have.
I think that that I
experienced it very .
. . I mean, still experience it.
One of my friends, her
name is Leigh Bardugo.
She said something sort
of funny the other night.
She said, every time an author
opens a book, they look at the page
and they go, wait, wait,
how do I book again?
Like how do I do this?
And it's very true.
So, first of all, know
that you're not alone.
But I would say be kind to yourself.
It is okay if you're writer and
you can't write all the time.
Particularly if you're
not published yet.
It is very, very difficult to .
. . I know very few people
who are able to write fulltime
if they're not published.
Because they need a
job to pay the bills.
So, I used to write
in elbows of time,
15 minutes here, 20 minutes there.
Whatever I could do.
And that really helped me.
But in terms of sort of facing
the failure in your own mind,
really take it a day at a time.
And when you do have
successes, whatever they are,
if you finish a paragraph
and you like it.
If you finish a chapter
Celebrate that.
And remind yourself of it.
And if it's something you've
done that you're really proud of,
stick it on your wall so that
every time you hit that place
where you're like,
why am I doing this?
You can look up and you can see
it, and you can remind yourself
of why you're putting
yourself through it.
So, I hope that helps.
>> It does.
Thank you, so much.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
On this side.
>> Hi. What character both ones
you write and you don't write,
can you relate to the most?
And which characters
sort of inspire you.
>> Sabaa Tahir: I'm really
inspired by the Commandant.
No, I'm joking.
She's evil.
In case any of you were wondering.
I am inspired by, I love Hermione.
She's one of my favorite characters.
I think Hermione has a wonderful
sort of questing imagination.
And I would really love
it if she became real
and could be my best friend.
And I'm trying to think
of other characters.
In my own books, it's
a little bit easier.
Because I kind of draw
most of them from me.
But I probably relate the most
to the main character of Elias.
He is sort of this angsty,
like morally tortured person
who feels like he doesn't fit in.
And you know, always feels like
he's kind of doing stuff wrong.
You know, I can't relate to
like the soldier side of him.
Like he can fight and
beat people up and stuff.
And I'm not, that's not
something I'm skilled at.
Though I sometimes wish it was.
But I definitely really [inaudible].
In a sense I relate
to all my characters.
They are little pieces of me.
I think that you have
to whether it's a hero
or villain, or something in between.
You kind of have to really
understand your characters
from their soul outward.
Otherwise, they become
caricatures and cut outs.
So, even my villains, I
definitely to some degree,
I absolutely relate to them.
Because in their minds,
they're not villains.
They're just doing their thing.
And if other people are
getting in their way .
. . You know.
So, I think that in
terms of who I relate
to all of them to some degree.
But Hermione is definitely
my favorite character.
And Professor McGonagall, actually.
I always find a way to bring
Harry Potter into my talks.
I don't think I've had a
single one in two years
where Harry Potter hasn't shown up.
So, thank you for giving
me that opportunity.
I appreciate it.
>> First, I want to thank you
because I think you're a really
good role model for aspiring writers
because you're so transparent.
Especially on your Instagram.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Yes.
Thank you.
Someone from my publishing
house was like, are you okay?
Are you going to finish the book?
Are you going to have a breakdown?
I was like, I don't
know, not sure, yet.
Sorry. Go on.
>> So, leading off of that, I was
wondering, you've spoken in the past
about expanding the
world and writing
about other characters' experiences.
And is that still something
that you're thinking you'll do?
Maybe after you taken
a bit of a break.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Yes.
[Laughs] That's all I can say.
>> Thank you.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
>> Hi. My question is aside from
failure were there any other factors
that motivated you to write?
>> Sabaa Tahir: There were.
Yes. Failure was the main one.
But my kids are probably one
of my biggest motivations.
They are two little brown boys.
And I want them to see
themselves in books.
I want them to pick up a book and
think that they can be heroes of it.
And that people who look like
them can be the heroes of it.
That's why these new covers
were so important to me.
[Applause] Thank you.
Having a brown girl
on the front of a book
and a Middle-Eastern coated
guy on the front of the .
. . but you can't really see
him as well in this cover.
But particularly in the
first cover you can kind
of see his face a little bit better.
It was very important to me.
So, that's absolutely
a motivating factor.
And then, actually, my
stubbornness was very motivating.
When I was a kid, my
parents hated it.
So, I want to tell any small
children in the audience
if you are stubborn and
your parents give you grief.
Don't worry.
It can be very helpful
later in life.
So, yes, I was like I
have to write this story.
And by God, I am going to do it.
>> Thank you.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
>> Hi. So, I guess my question
is what was your favorite book
growing up?
And what's your favorite book now?
Or have they changed and has
that influenced you at all?
>> Sabaa Tahir: That is
an excellent question.
It has influence my writing.
My favorite book growing up was
"Seven Daughters and Seven Sons."
It was about this Iraqi girl
who is the youngest child
in her family, or, sorry.
The middle child in
her family and kind
of goes off to try to save them.
And it was the first time
that I had seen a book
with a person who looked me.
And she was not, you know,
either a villain or a character
who didn't have any rights or a
character who was sort of put down.
She was her own person.
She was fully formed.
And she a badass.
So, that was my favorite
book as a kid.
As an adult, this is a
really, really generic answer.
But The Harry Potter books.
No one in audience who knows me
should be at all shocked about this.
I think that those
books changed my life.
And I was 18 when I
started reading them.
And they're really
what helped me believe
that I could become
a young adult author.
Thanks Jo Rowling.
>> Hi. I was wondering
how you juggle writing
from multiple viewpoints.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Okay.
So, there is a few
different things that I do.
One thing is when I do the
first draft I don't try
to make them sound different.
I just write in one voice.
I put their voices as an edit.
I call it a tonal edit.
And so, usually what I do is I
go find music that inspires me
and makes me think of
each of these characters.
I watch movies that like, you
know, if I'm writing Elias,
I'm going to go watch
"Apocalypse Now" right?
And like, war movies and stuff.
And movies about angsty boys.
And if I'm thinking about
Laia, I'm going to listen
to very specific kinds of music.
And that's sort of going
to get me into her head.
The other thing that I did to help
me understand my characters better,
is I try to find people in the
real world who mirrored them.
No, I have not found an Elias.
Sorry, guys.
But I did find a West
Point Cadet who I talked
to about being in a military school.
I interviewed him about that.
I talked to a police sergeant about
what it was like to be a warrior.
Basically, to have
the soul of a warrior.
I talked to a woman who was
an FBI agent and she worked
on a special task force
for gangs In San Jose.
And she was really fascinating.
Because when I met her it was like
meeting an older version of Helene.
She had like .
. . and I had already written Helene
but she had blonde
hair, ice-blue eyes.
And she was a totally badass.
And I would never,
ever mess with her.
But it was really fascinating
to talk to her because, she,
in particular helped me
understand this sort of balance
between when you have the soul of
a warrior but you have a family.
And how it can tear it apart.
And how you end up having to
put one or the other first.
And it's just a really
difficult balance.
So, for me research, like
primary sources, trying to figure
out who these people
are at their very core.
And writing from there
as opposed to writing it
and then sort of adding it in.
That's how I approached getting
the different viewpoints,
you know, right, I guess.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
Yes. Hello.
Hello small one.
>> My question is how do
you write with children?
I'm at home and finding
that time, that balance,
and then keeping your
mind on your book.
Keeping your mind sane
with your children.
How did you survive?
>> Sabaa Tahir: That's
an excellent question.
The thing is it's that
it's a constant struggle.
It's not something that
I fully worked out yet.
And I'm just going to
be honest with you.
I do, like I said before,
and I'll talk
about it a little bit more I write
in elbows of time a lot of time.
Where if I have 10 minutes,
if I have 5 minutes,
I will write whatever I can.
I'll try to keep my
computer with me.
I'll try to keep a notebook with me.
And I'll just write.
I can edit a page in 15
minutes or 20 minutes.
And somebody once gave me
this interesting number.
She said, and I'm sure some famous
white dude author has said this
as well.
But, one of my friends said,
if you write three pages a day,
you have a book in a year.
And I think, that's really true.
So, it's just about finding
whatever time you can.
That's what it was about for me.
Finding whatever time I could
to get in whatever I could.
And then the biggest thing
is that I had family support.
So, my husband was
incredibly supportive.
I could not have written the
first book without him, you know,
helping me, helping me find time.
And even now, the last two
weeks, I was finishing my draft.
Was failing at my draft.
And I worked every
night until one or two,
or sometimes three in the morning.
So, who's taking the
school at 7 a.m?
Who is getting them ready?
It's not me.
So, just having your family support.
And asking for help, too.
I would say is another thing
that I really recommend.
When I was living in D.C. I
asked my in-laws for support.
They were very supportive.
Now I'm out in California and I
ask my family and friends for help
out there when I need it.
There is no shame in that.
You just got to let them
you're following your dream.
That's a good cause, guys.
>> Thank you.
>> Sabaa Tahir: You're welcome.
>> So, hi.
I found your books really
inspiring for everyone
and especially young writers.
And if you could say something to
them right now, what would you say?
>> Sabaa Tahir: I would tell
young writers the pieces
of advice I usually share.
The first one is read.
A ton. And not just
what you want to write.
Read outside that.
Read poetry.
Read the newspaper.
Read the Washington Post.
[Laughs] Read nonfiction.
Read, if you really love
mysteries, read romance novels.
If you really love romance
novels, read thrillers.
Just read outside what
you normally read.
Because that is going to be
thing that helps you the most.
The second thing is don't give up.
It took me, like I said, seven
years and ten months to see my book
on shelves after the idea
first germinated in my head.
That is a long time.
That's a long time to be like, I
can do it, I can do it, I can do it.
It sometimes takes forever.
So, definitely don't give up.
Have faith in yourself.
And the last bit of advice
is a little bit meaner.
And that advice is don't
make excuses for yourself.
I made a lot of excuses for
myself as a young writer.
I was too busy.
I had children.
I had a life.
I had an ill relative.
You know, whatever it was.
I wanted to see my friends.
I had all these excuses that
I had built up for myself.
But in the end, that's
all they were.
Writers write.
They find a way.
Whether you're ill,
well, or old, or young,
or you know in school, or in prison.
People find a way to do it.
And I always come back to
Paul Kalanithi who wrote
"When Breath Becomes Air"
when he had stage IV lung
cancer and was dying.
Like if he can do that,
you all can write a book.
That's it.
>> Thank you so much.
>> You're welcome.
Yes. Hello.
>> One of the things that
impressed me the most
about your story was even though you
developed an early fear of failure,
you didn't take the easy way out.
And just not try.
But you kept on being
persistent in spite of that.
You didn't let the fear of
failure stop you from trying.
How is it that you developed that?
>> Sabaa Tahir: I have to give
a lot of credit to my parents.
I had a tiger dad.
He was very much like, you will
be awesome or you will be nothing.
I think that my parents
were a huge part of it.
They really, really helped me
understand that if I wanted
to be anybody, I could not give up.
And then I do think that part of it
was really a natural stubbornness.
I'm the youngest of three kids.
You know you have two older brothers
who were typical older brothers.
And who definitely didn't let
me get away with anything.
And I think that also
had a big part of it.
And also, there is this
thing called self-talk.
Apparently Navy Seals do it.
Just saying.
But what you basically do
is you keep telling yourself
that you can do something.
Whatever it is.
And you keep reminding yourself
of that in any way you can.
And I found that really helpful.
And we have about two minutes,
so maybe two more questions.
Let's go to this side.
>> Hi. I wanted to know if it was
hard to keep a story line going
with different books and not
let it be repetitive, I guess?
>> Sabaa Tahir: It can be.
Yes. But generally, I have this sort
of story of the characters plotted
out in my head, like
all the way until death.
And so, it's not as hard as I think
it could have been had I not planned
out the books ahead of time.
That doesn't make them
easier to write by the way.
>> Thank you.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Hello.
>> Would you ever consider
writing a superhero novel?
I know they're a big trend in
[inaudible] literature lately?
>> Sabaa Tahir: I would.
Yes. I would.
>> What superhero would
you want to .
. .
>> Sabaa Tahir: Ms. Marble.
[Laughs] I haven't
thought about this at all.
Not once. Yes.
>> Hi. First, I just want to say
that I really love your new covers
because it's one of the first
times that I've seen myself
on a cover as a brown girl.
>> Sabaa Tahir: Yes.
Thank you.
I'm so glad you like them.
>> I was wondering
how do you work to get
over writer's block
when you have it?
>> Sabaa Tahir: Oh,
I love this question.
Because I didn't used
to have an answer.
And then one of my
friends provided an answer.
And I have since stole it from her.
So, Alison Goodman who
wrote the "Eon" books
and the "Dark Days Club" books says
that she doesn't believe
in writer's block.
She believes in writer's pause.
And that's what I've been sort
of thinking about recently.
It's not that I'm blocked.
It's that something has gone
wrong in the past whatever,
however many pages I've written.
That has made me not
know what to do next.
So, what I do is I go
back to the last place
that the story has worked.
And I start from there.
And I try to start looking at it.
Okay, this is where
the story was flowing.
What happened afterward
that isn't working.
Generally, it's something like my
characters' motivations are right.
Or the conflict doesn't quite fit.
There is something off.
So, if you're struggling
with writer's pause,
go back to the last place that
felt good and start from there.
And start sort of going through.
And one more question
and then we'll be done.
>> thank you for coming
and joining us today.
And my question is where do
you get your inspiration from?
>> Sabaa Tahir: So, I get my
inspiration almost primarily
from news stories that I read.
And more recently reading about
the refugee crisis in Europe
and the Middle East has
been a huge inspiration
for the stuff I've written.
It has found its way into
Torch, in particular,
and it will be finding
its way into Reaper.
So, yes. that's why I said
read the Washington Post.
And with that.
Thank you, guys very
much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.